have you seen all these protests around
the world supporting Palestine even
after these abhorent attacks by Hamas on
Israeli civilians it's an important
reminder that the movement for the
liberation of Palestinians is very
different than this violent terrorizing
group called Hamas the vast majority of
Palestinians are not Hamas they simply
want freedom and dignity and autonomy
and yet their land has been sliced up
built on and is under constant control
and surveillence by Israeli military and
citizens when I was reporting in the
West Bank I saw that this is also a form
of violence it is a quieter and less
flashy form of violence it doesn't make
the same kind of news but it is violence
nonetheless and yet it in no way
justifies what Hamas has done in
launching these attacks these protests
remind us that there is a bigger more
legitimate movement at play here one
that should not be conflated with Hamas
and their horrible actions in the last
few days